you had a terrible thing happened to you
you're a personal assistant beat you up
right one of his good friends stun guns
him in his sleep and beats them up on
the front lawn where were you tell me
what you had done retrace your steps the
movie Joe Dirt we were doing we were
editing that day okay so we're in the
editing Society feeling very powerful
cutting tape do you bring chicks into
the editing room so that they can see
you in with all your powers no but when
you come in my house is a tripwire that
plays SNL on a loop that's smart and a
little bit of just shoot me clips yeah
so so Skippy and I who you've met we
edited the movie there was no fight we
went home I said let's go out tomorrow
night
perfectly normal she went in the house
and you laid down the bed no I didn't go
to begs it was 7:00 right so I stayed up
till 8:30 and had a cordial took a
bubble bath little Calgon no be honest
you will I go to sleep at around 12 I go
to bed 6 a.m. it's dark I look up he's
in my room
does he have keys to her I don't really
have keys per se but yeah he got it I
mean he has codes an alarm code okay Wow
what do you live in Fort Knox he had all
the coding star overseas right so I go I
go to bed 6:00 a.m. he's right in the
doorway and you know you're so out of it
that early you don't know what's going
on and I got scared which I should have
been and I go it's just a silhouette
because the lights are off there's a
light behind him he said the alarm
company called and they sent him over
cuz my alarm went off uh-huh
and I didn't know I was like no and he
goes so there's nobody here and I go no
and he punched me in the face punched
you in the face and then what Amy or the
stun gun hit you with this thing up
what's it feel like to be stun gun
share with my audience I felt it in the
chest but if it was totally maxed out I
wouldn't have gotten up it really should
have been low yeah well you were able to
move I was able to move but I was within
seconds on the ground getting pummeled
did you say did you at that point say
with what's going on or what are you
doing III was awake you know I was awake
maybe 15 seconds and it's dark and I
know I think it's a dream and I'm just
getting the kicked out of me why do you
think he did it
hey dad dad I still don't know so all of
a sudden you company oh girl I had like
a dead sleep he the guy punches you he's
on W punch yeah I was like watching a
movie because I'm watching like myself
get beat up and I flipped over backwards
it got on my feet and I go what do you
do oh you like I got a Jackie Chan
so you flipped over you know I guess I
just squirm my way out and give it ease
350 and I'm being generous weighs 350
pounds at least yeah right so he's on a
mission to this is like a different guy
something's going on I don't know why I
mean he didn't he sort of get out of
breath he's a you know big heavy guy was
he he's still breathing hard to this day
right so let me understand something you
wear him out yeah I squirm out of it
somehow with my wiry Pilates body so I I
get out and I pop up and I've are I
already see blood all over tonight off
and he won't talk I go what's going on
what's going came at me again I got out
my shirt rip what was he wearing
was he making sure he was wearing a
jockstrap and a sailor shirt you just
gotta know what he was sleeping in dude
yeah kind of a cropped guest jacket I
don't know what do you sleep it
seriously no serious were you naked
David were you naked I was wearing
actual pajamas and I shirt nice you know
like a Gold's Gym like I work out or
something like what's up how much do
bench do you wear that hand to bed
because Howard that's not fair
I think you wearing that hat as a
disguise from skipper we will recognize
you anyway so might be on the premises
so explain to me something so that now
you've you've gotten up he's stunned on
you he punched you in the face yeah how
do you make your way down to the front
lawn he grabs me again on my shirt rips
and I squirm out of that now I'm hauling
ass right you're running down he's
running after me he's
a half second behind me isn't running 32
years it's he screaming something is he
saying anything
no I'm screaming what are you saying
stop it there's a lot of chicken oysters
coming out of me I was I was like what
are you doing what's up I by now I'm
kind of awake realizing there's blood
all over I'm just we're actually very
smart to start running like a panic
button or something there's two alarm
panic buttons but at that time he's a
half second behind me and every time I
turn I'm getting punched err yeah I'm
just trying to get away to think and I
get out the driveway and you think your
life is gonna be over seriously a
driveway and it's like the Hotel
California cuz there's all the gates I
can't leave you're stuck in your own
head alright so I got to come back and
he's right on me
yes do you have the gates to keep out
people but now you're locked in right
how ironic and it's codes and by the
time I would punch my code I'd be you
know yeah
um even if I got to a neighbor I'd be
did you start to think at this point I
was thinking did you think that you're
gonna be dead yeah you did go through
your mind at that point like oh my god I
just guy's gonna kill me and my Jo yeah
and what do you think of at that point
like because it was so different than
anything I'd ever seen him like that
there it was no rhyme or reason for this
thing and did you try to reason with him
at all other than don't try to kill me I
was just screaming like what are you
doing and he grabbed me again threw me
on the cement this time I started fight
back and I punched him probably five
times in the face no kidding yeah and I
go this when I got a few shots in it
made him like over a second he's still
got the stun gun so I come in
slam the door when I lock it he hits it
like a rhino at the exact same time and
I can't believe it didn't fly open
I got it in time Wow and I see there's
blood handprints where I did it and I
went into my room and slid down and pull
my shotgun out of my oh wow my bet smart
so you have a shotgun and I had it
yeah it's loaded it's ready to go and
did you call the police how did you how
did you uh uh no I just held the shotgun
up for the door and said I was gonna
shoot through it and he left and he said
I'm gonna boogie yeah Wow now have you
spoken to him since this happened
no you haven't spoken there's a
restraining order he can't come here
you're right banging order he who's he
in jail no he is not in jail now he
played it not skinny the other day
music leaves out free yeah he's on out
on bail or something got bail or
something I mean I think he's back to
the way he was I think he had a mom
blackout or aren't you afraid for your
life seriously I mean I do have a
bodyguard and stuff you should know I
think you should know I don't it's good
to see you though he's not going
anywhere you're gonna try and pick up
chicks trying to be cool
[Laughter]
[Music]